OpenFlow makes modifying forwarding behavior easy,
because forwarding decisions are based on
matches on the openflow 10-tuple. There to switching is simply a match
on the destination Mac address which has a corresponding action of forwarding
out of particular output port. If all of the fields are specified for
forwarding out a particular output port then
we have flow switching behavior. If all
of the flow specifications are wild carded
except for say the source MAC address to
make a forwarding or drop decision Then
we have a firewall. Constructing a firewall
is as simple as building a hash table that stores key value pairs where the
table maps a switch and source MAC address to a true or false value
depending on whether traffic should be forwarded
or dropped. The controller Might then only decide
to forward traffic if the firewall entry maps to true. It is important to
emphasize the performance implications of caching the
decisions at the switch. So, packets only reach
the controller if there's no flow table entry at the
switch. If on the other hand, there is a float
table entry at the switch, then the switch can simply
forward the packets rather than sending them to the controller.
So when a controller decides to take an action on
a packet, it installs that action as a flow table
entry in the switch, and that decision or flow table
entry is cached until that flow table entry expires. In summary,
customizing control is easy. We've explored how to
use the POX controller to develop alternate control
programs. And it's possible to turn a switch
into a firewall in less than 40 lines
of python code. We also explored the performance
benefits of caching rules and decisions, to avoid
sending too much traffic to the controller. As
we know, forwarding performance in a switch is as
fast but whenever we have to send traffic
to the controller it slows things down. So whatever
decisions we can cache in the switch will
only serve to improve the performance of the network.